هذا صحيح تمامًا كما تعلم
أننا تعرضنا
لحوادث مؤسفة قبل أن تعرف كثيرًا من المرات
أن حادث طائرة
هو للأسف أن الطائرة الأخرى
ليست في حالة جيدة على
الإطلاق ، فهي مقلوبة رأسًا على عقب
مع
هبوط واضح رأسًا على عقب واستمرارها
على الأرض من أجل الخير  المسافة
قبل أن تستقر هناك ،
يمكنك رؤية الأنف مقطوعًا
منه وهذا بالضبط هو المكان الذي ستكون فيه المظلة
، لذا أكره أن أعتقد أنه كان هناك
أي فقدان
لأي من هؤلاء الطيارين هنا في المعجبين هنا في
قاعدة القوات الجوية المتقدمة
لا يبدو الأمر جيدًا ومن المؤكد
أنه من الصعب التحدث عنه من
الصعب الإبلاغ عن
كونك زميل طيار عسكري زميل
طيار على الإطلاق
وأنا أعلم أن هناك الكثير من
الطيارين والأفراد المعنيين هناك على الأرض
يتقدمون وحول
القاعدة المستديرة و
أنت تعلم أنك تتساءل عما إذا كنت تعرف
المدرب ، فتتساءل عما إذا كنت تعرف
الطالب
الذي تعرفه ، لدي أصدقاء هنا في
فانس المطار الجديد